it's like someone just broke into the
studio every day Bill de Blasio's only
five days into his pipe dream quest for
the White House but speculation is
already swirling about who should
succeed the disastrous Democrat as New
York City mayor the paper floating this
this is New York Sun the idea of
Alexander Acacio Cortez as being the
perfect candidate were to run for the
top job in the city I'll bring you a
quote out of the article and I just
ripped it on the edges there I couldn't
find a knife one can imagine that the
prospect of mayoral race would look
attractive to the young firebrand with a
we don't mind saying quick wit and taste
for the limelight
what kind of mayor with a Oh CV what do
you think Dean well one I think that
this shows an obvious lack of
imagination or total laziness or they
really don't want her to be in the
Congress yeah right so they wanted they
wanted me here like get her off the
stage because she is now be like besides
president Trump probably the most
popular politician was no offense to the
Biden team like the mayor's the mayor's
office you have to have executive
decision she's been in Congress for
about six months so I like her executive
decision-making makes Bill DeBlasio look
like Mike Bloomberg that is why I think
she should just stay where she is she's
in she's in that pole position too she
could be a kingmaker right I find her
decisive I'm confident charismatic and
hard-working Jesse can you vote me on
any of those four qualities that you
just want her to run for mayor so you
can cover her on Fox and Friends single
day you know in the New York Post would
love a OCS mayor and all four things I
said 100% it's true she's got everything
that you said but like Dana said she
does not have the technical acumen the
managerial experience to run the city
because the city needs to be run you
can't just tweet about the price of
Quesada talk about socialism in theory
because in practice our city has to run
smoothly and in a way it might be good
for her to be mayor because she would
run the city so fast into the ground you
definitely get a Republican after the
first term we are on automatic pilot
right now Emily reorge
you have a mayor that works out at the
show or the after I get where we live at
ten o'clock he works out at 12 o'clock
he gets to the office and according to
the New York Post lays down in his
office with the door open with the
newspaper on his head and the city's
still running why a OSI is if nothing if
not a workaholic she'd be great I hear
what you're saying he definitely is just
like rock bottom and that's why he has
an 18% approval rate in this city um
you're right that there's no worse that
she can do especially given the energy
bill that the mayor just passed which
all the buildings have to be like made
of seaweed or whatever definitely option
C I think it's wishful thinking on the
part of the Democrats to remove her from
the national stage because she is
driving policy and conversation do you
guys know what good American is it's the
Khloe Kardashian jeans line bear with me
for a second basically I get their
emails whatever and it was like just
like hoops and red lipstick go together
on AOC so too does our look so basically
in all facets of kind of normal life
outside of the political sphere sphere
people are referencing her she is a
goddess to them and so you're right that
it needs to be harnessed in some way
think the Democrats but they want to
contain her and their reasoning by the
way of saying oh she will probably be
fatigued if the Republicans take back
over the house in 2020 I think is really
infantilizing and kind of lame would you
wear those jeans you know gee mom jeans
for me that's but I must say I think
that Dan is on point I think the rest of
you missed it here Dana's on point in
first this is a conversation among
Republicans in the Sun people at a
dinner party Upper East Side types and
having a conversation this is not this
is not the same electorate and this and
the second thing what guess what they
are thinking Oh de Blasio hit rock
bottom but then you're saying oh she's
going to take us further down that's
craziness
I bet she would be better I think I
think Mike Bloomberg thought that this
was great training I think Rudy Guiliani
thought it was great training you
dealing with national security you're
dealing with a big school system you're
dealing with a large police force all
these issues are there the question is
does Alexandria kasnia Cortez get kicked
out the Republicans regain the house
next time around
does she decide hmm maybe I should
challenge Charles Schumer in New York
for the Senate seat one I know
America's mayor and AOC is know
America's mayor yeah thank God he paved
the roads we stopped shoplifters
pickpockets yeah boys yes she'll be the
pickpocket oh you know we're you know
what I'm gonna use one of Jesse's lines
he opened the door for de Blasio his
policies I'm saying bet those kind of
harsh policies Giuliani time and the
lake boy I tell you it changed the
attitude I think those are the things
that clean this oh I see very good hey
listen I'm pretty sure I'm responsible
for bringing in this block and taking us
out